have you ever heard a word for the first
time a word like I don't know
crepuscular which by the way is an
adjective describing Twilight and then
the next day you see crepuscular again
in a novel and then you see it again the
next day in your biology textbook and
you start to wonder how is it possible
that I've gone the first 20 years of my
life without ever seeing the word
crepuscular and now in the last week
I've seen crepuscular three times
I know I've experienced this strong
feeling of coincidence before many times
and there's a name for it it's called
the baader-meinhof phenomena nobody
really knows why it's called that the
baader-meinhof group was a late 20th
century left-wing militant faction from
West Germany it's likely that the person
who gave it that name just happened to
be awash in coincidental baader-meinhof
references the more scientific name for
this phenomenon is the frequency
illusion and it's just another example
of our old friend the cognitive bias at
work see when we see something for the
first time and then many times directly
thereafter it can lead us to believe
that there's a greater synchronicity at
work in the world around us perhaps it's
an artifact of determinism the feeling
that everything happens for a reason the
coincidence we feel is just too
astronomically unlikely but of course
the truth is that most bordering on all
things don't happen for reason despite
our intuition that they do and yet it's
just that intuition activated in the
baader-meinhof phenomenon that gives us
an interesting look into the machinery
of the mind our brains are essentially
pattern recognizing superheroes able to
find meaning in countless pieces of data
whether it's our ability to see words in
a newspaper word search or to work out
through fine mathematics the natural
laws of the universe
for this reason stimuli which are
excited sort of sit in wait at the fore
of the brain for similar stimuli with
which to identify a pattern in other
words you may have seen the word
crepuscular a number of times in your
life but your brain just wasn't
interested the frequency illusion is
augmented by two other phenomena first
the Reed
see effect the cognitive bias that
inflates the importance of recent
stimuli or observations and second by
the confirmation bias which in this case
is precisely your belief that you're
seeing this new thing all over the place
and the frequency illusion can become
confirmation bias when our passive
experience of repeatedly seeing a new
thing turns into an active search for
still more examples of the magic that
summons it but what's more interesting
to me about this phenomenon is not the
coincidences that you think you see but
all the patterns that are zipping by in
your day to day life that you don't
register at all the baader-meinhof
illusion proves that we only see the
things that we're looking out for this
can be bad in the case of confirmation
bias but it also goes to show how
ignorant can be maintained through a
lack of active learning the more you
prime your mind by reading and writing
to see new patterns the more reality
will unfold before you as an
extraordinary mechanism of natural laws
the more humanity will show itself to be
an empathetic and beautiful mess of
self-delusions and cognitive biases I
could end this video like everybody else
who writes articles about the subject
does by saying that you'll probably see
the baader-meinhof phenomenon again
sometime soon but of course those people
were talking about the baader-meinhof
phenomenon merely as a ruse to get you
to take more notice of the word
crepuscular because that's what I was
doing hey everybody thanks for watching
sorry I was a little bit late last week
with the video I was traveling all over
God's creation I just didn't have the
time to finish it um I was wondering if
you like the understanding arthouse
feature that I did last week it's a
little bit different but I was thinking
of doing it as a series sprinkled in
between other videos tell me what you
think also I sort of like putting out
the video on Monday I might continue to
do that instead of Friday I don't know I
just feel like it gives more opportunity
for people to see it the weekend people
usually check out let me know what you
think about that as well follow me on
tumblr and twitter discuss this video in
the comments and post this on reddit if
you have any heart at all for me and can
to do this and I love you so much for
that I will see you next time